if you asked MJ would you rather PRI a
mind or a seventh ring you'd say a
seventh [__] ring talking about
different objectives what is yours be
rich
[Music]
possible trying to train some legs and
I'm going to Mr Alex harosi gym a bunch
of old broken men they need a lot of
warmup what's
up so we're doing legs what's the plan
all right you want to just alternate
like we'll go I'll go One Direction you
go the other
this thing deceptively heavy I'll do
whatever you do you want to go yeah
let's
[Music]
go what's the heaviest you had in the
offseason you7 me the heaviest I've ever
been I kind of stopped trying to push
food right now and I'm going to slowly
bring it down from here cuz I mean for
you to keep winning it's like you don't
need more size right I have a little
room do you ever year like 2 lbs okay
and I can always like be leaner and I
keep putting on and I keep making weight
so yeah we just keep it
working Jesus I could have warned youall
now it's a counterbalance for Russian
lro
okay come on deep breath use your breath
come
on keep
going yep
woo easy came out the top of
there it's counterintuitive that once
you succeed at bodybuilding everything
comes with this success of bodybuilding
prevents you from succeeding in
bodybuilding yeah feel like speaking and
guest posing yeah like traveling
podcasts whatever and not wanting to
wait till you retire to start a business
and all this [__] well I don't think you
should no like starting a business when
you when you retire is like no one cares
anymore we definitely Force grow WE Post
we do 450 posts a week how often do you
film that every day no it used so we
used to it's like it's changed over time
before in the very beginning it was once
every 90 days every one full day really
and we do like a 100 clotes just that
was it yeah and then it switched to
every other week and then it became
Fridays and then now I was like you know
I think I'm better if I'm fresher and I
do few or more yeah and so that's what
or something like in the moment it's
exactly what it is basically D message
to me is like we're ready if you feel
like stepping away at any time so I'm
doing my [__] in the morning if I like
lightning strikes I go down and I talk
wasn't as tough of mind I got to ask
done any seminars in there was no one in
the crowd and filmed it yeah yeah no I
did cuz we why the team there but like
had this Theory I do better live at live
things than I do in front of the camera
just more you know interesting and so I
was like can I approximate that so then
we did the whole setup we did the
presentations the stage
and then they s my teens out in the
audience and I gave the presentation but
it it's not the same you're not talking
to empty chairs but there's still it
still mostly empty chairs like teams
can't fill a r yeah we opted out of
doing that we did it like four times and
then doing it yeah and so then I started
doing Instagram lives and that was way
more like fun yeah also cuz it's like
the room's got 2,000 people in it or
whatever you know so that's nice I mean
if you can present in front of a [__]
empty chair that's harder than a crowd
so yeah right just the on light yeah I
had this tweet that went kind of viral
it's like if you're like 16 to 25 like
just get in shape yeah like cuz once
you're in shape you can stay in shape
but like you have the time and you'll
get different priorities later yeah so
it's like just do it then you have all
the F yeah I'm grateful that I I I was
obsessed from 15 I start I was 14 until
I stopped Compu 25 it was right around
when I started my I was 23 but I guess I
start I stopped Compu 23 when you're 23
yeah when it stopped got my state
record I think not National fair enough
there's 50
states I think 23 when I dropped no 22
is when I dropped at a university and
that's when I started doing it full-time
were you uh like a junior or senior side
I there for four years but on my second
year of school so you you lived but I
was Jack you're that's all it matters
which in your actual life that is all
that matter exactly it paid off yeah
what do you think you to do lift weights
for a living you're like actually yes
that sounds great yeah I literally would
spend 4 hours in the weight room and
then like be in the cafeteria all day
right that life right
yeah are you the only member of raw
Athletic
Club no this is our public gym oh is it
we just opened it like 6 weeks
ago it's a Tas Shore Warehouse where
your private gym is no my private gyms
away from there this is in Nashville
Florida it's in Florida where our
partners is in Nashville with carbon
culture maybe that's what we oh no no
car culture yeah yeah I worked out the
gym yeah he do some of the formulation
stuff he's actually our partner in the
in the business he used to own the
manufacturer and then we partnered with
them and we got pricing and help on our
payment plan and all the [__] yeah
cuz I knew he did that I remember I got
connected his location operator when I
went in knew who I was he was like you
should talk to our owner and I was like
I you know whatever he's like no he's
you know blah blah so I was like fine so
I think we had a phone call or something
yeah yeah he's a really good guy he's SM
yeah I know he sounded that way because
I was when I was getting in the
supplement business he quoted us uh for
manufacturing oh yeah yeah he was one of
the I think he's the final three bits we
going another company but probably
should have gone with him all right
bulgarians yeah so we've got uh I've got
this thing you got a proper pad I do
have a proper pad fancy I usually set up
next to this pole here just have them in
the balance
on use a dumbbell or um I yeah usually I
just grab a dumbbell how do you do it
yeah but I just never held on something
oh well that's how you cheat that's how
you do it exactly here I'm going to put
a little bit of music on cuz we have a
sound system he silence well that's kind
of nice hearing you
[Music]
pant now I'm going to try it out see
you're my
inspiration sorry you're my
inspiration good like what motivates you
and I'll just be like this guy right
here this assle comes in my gym and
looks more than me yeah that's a
motivation it
[Music]
is I used to really like uh
barbes like they used to tear my glutes
up more than anything back when I had
glutes they're great walking leses are
[__] incredible for leg grow you can
load them you're such a [__] to do like
I left this whole Corridor empty for
that yeah for walking away just cuz Lea
doesn't cuz Lea's hardcore two play
walking
lunges yeah that's the biggest I did 225
225 I was when I was strong and young
and and that's I was eating 6,000
calories a day I just was like I read
this thing it was like insulin's the
most anabolic hormone and I was like
done and so more food it was the little
that I met she used to make me a box of
pancakes for breakfast it was a cake I
do half a thing of syrup and I'd pass
out
again and then I wake up I'd work out
I'd have a 1200 calor Shake then I'd
have a burrito double meat double rice
sour cream chips on the side guac and
then I'd get back home for dinner and
I'd have one box of pasta and one jar of
tomato sauce that's cuz a box pasta is
70 gr of protein yeah I eat pasta a lot
I digest it great yeah me too and rice I
do really well with bosmal rice I could
just eat unlimited amounts can you still
eat like that no I can talk about though
yeah I eat like out like I go to like a
nice restaurant I have a steak and then
like chips and something and I'm like oh
my
stomach all right you want to do side
backs oh oh o starting to feel it like
gluteous yeah I haven't done those in
the long pan with the spit squat yeah so
usually when I do my warmup I'll do this
guy this yeah not for this I mean I'm
more but I'll do that guy and I'll do
that the hip flexor one like multi down
GL I actually do this up like up yeah
but I think I needed a Mobility stuff
more than the shr honey you probably
could argue that if you took 20 minutes
out of your workout and put that into
like constructive Mobility you'd be
better off well I mean I did way more
weight than I normally do so yeah that
alone yeah literally today especially so
I put um I put one rule for the whole
gym is that this machine keeps four
plates out oh you want five yeah I think
so
[Music]
so do we plan on leaving this building
or is this like home this is for the
next 3 to5 3 to five I like Vegas a lot
more than I think I've liked any City
I've lived in as an adult it's just like
it's a non-judgmental city everyone
pretends to be something and they come
to Vegas and they like let their real
selves out yeah and I just like being
here and so also it's not political cuz
it's for tourism so it has to be just
neutral so it's not political at all try
like it's great for traveling in and out
everybody I know comes to Vegas once
year anyways so I can see honey pill if
I lived in Cincinnati I wouldn't never
see you right so I get to like I benefit
from those we have direct flight
everywhere out 4 hours from the beach in
the mountains yeah 30 minutes on the
lake we've got the best student dining
and shows in the world it's
taxfree it's dry which I personally like
UFC's here it's their old building I
mean it's a perfect setup for this yeah
t you don't need like warehouse space
too no have to deal with that [__]
right nice
[Music]
nice those a little quar oh yeah just
your time under tension is crav cuz you
can't skip for the weak
Parts it's like that is the weak part
right yeah well yeah it's interesting
cuz now you have this B of like I want
to push but like the risk reward of
pushing goes down a lot literally cuz
like you really just want to maintain on
as little effort as possible or little
risk as possible it's hard especially
because they added weight cap to
everybody in my weight my category
except me I got like 2 lb and everyone
else got 6 to8
why just because I was unfair people
were complaining that people at the
height of 61 had an unfair Advantage
like statistically or something like no
people were just complaining
I was the only one in that category so
that happened and then now everyone got
better so I actually have to improve and
like fine tuna but I'm also like the
most old broken guy in the category so I
also have to be the safest yeah what is
interesting from like an investor
perspective it's like Risk adjusted
return yeah like the same thing yeah if
you're at fifth place you should take
all the risks you can because if you
fail you lost nothing cuz no one cares
lit if you win it makes all the
difference exctly I've always found it
so interesting with repeat Champions
uhhuh like and most of them are like I
mean Michael Jon's content but he's not
happy he's a miserable [__] he
just found some way to continuously
drive his way in a miserable fashion
yeah and people look up to that and they
want to be that and I'm like he didn't
do it right yeah well he did but he
didn't right it's just like my goal is
my goal rather be happy and have peace
of mind rather than yeah and I think and
I think if you asked MJ would you rather
piece of mind or seventh ring you'd say
a seventh [__] ring oh yeah so I
think you Ronnie Coleman would you
rather be able to walk or have nine
ttles you'd say nine ttles yeah and
that's where like you zoom all the way
out and it's like making a judgment on
anyone else's goals in general is stupid
because their goals aren't the same
George yeah so I would do it different
no [__] you're different like I had
somebody a family member tell me they
were like I would never live my life
like you and I was like no [__] and I
would never live my life like you which
is why you have your life and I live my
life and good thing is you don't have to
live mine and I don't to live yours it's
interesting about how you define
champion too like I had to think about
it like a year ago I was like do I want
to be the richest man in the world and I
was like no I don't think that's my goal
so then I was going to ask you that well
you're talking about different
objectives what is yours honestly I want
to is it just be rich as possible no no
no it's not I see wealth as a measure of
my personal growth yeah because I see
entrepreneurship as the most
quantitative path of personal adment
it's more I want to be the richest man
that outs to become come not the richest
man in the world now if that happens to
become the richest man in the world cool
I'm not against it yeah but me measuring
my wealth against other people's is not
the right game for me yeah but me
measuring my wealth against what I
believe I can create is a game that I
can compete in and will always try to
compete and so me seeing like a really
hard thing for me was when we sold gym
launch my monthly cash flow cuz I was an
owner went to zero and I was like that's
a mind [__] yeah so I was like all of a
sudden even though I had a bunch of cash
in the bank account I felt poorer so I
was like okay this is weird
ooh and so I had to like re-calibrate
and that's so I had this year where I
started making content about like the
meaning of money and like all this stuff
that's when I had to redefine like what
where am I the most where do I grow the
most I grow the most when I work hard on
things worth doing and so then it was
like how do I Orient my life in a way
that I maximize the amount of hard work
I do on things worth doing and then once
I saw what those days looked like I had
a mentor of mine my first boss ever I'd
have like a really good week and I was
like that was like probably one of the
best weeks I've had in my life and she
was like not a profound person she was
like I'm pretty sure the secret of life
is living as many of those days in a row
as you can't yeah and she and it was
such a tactical like I was like so
that's what I'll do I'll I think what
are the days that I do my best and how
do I live that day as many times in a
row as I can and that's pretty much just
the path I've been on stuff that has
occurred has occurred but that's at
least how I think about it and your path
of feeling like best days are wealth
building for our personal wealth
building not like for yourself but your
own goals it's usually me creating stuff
and so like my arc happens to be
business related so like I draw like my
books are picture Buzz I draw pics about
business I write books about business I
make videos about business I make
podcasts about business like it's just
all I think about and so like if I
happen to do that about like electric
cars no one would care they'd be like oh
he's passionate about it it's sh that I
happen to be passionate about something
that makes money yeah but it's all I
think about I almost am more interested
in business than I am doing business
like my days I only do do business
hardcore 1 to two days a week the rest
of my days are making things that help
other people do business so like me like
doing this is this doing business I mean
we make media yeah you know but like
also me working out with people that I
care about that I enjoy is on my list of
things that I do on my best days you
enjoy yeah and so I respect that I feel
like a lot of people now are almost like
they there just so many opinions out
there of like what's right to the world
rather than to themselves like you said
when what's Like A Champion I had this
thing when I was young I said I always
talk about Champion mentality and had no
idea what it meant and I began to Define
it and now I need to consistently
reiterate that it's my definition of
what a champion is what is a champion to
me is that the true only thing that a
champion does is they make their own
rules because they don't give a [__]
with people think they just do whatever
they want I agree doesn't mean I'm
winning doesn't mean nothing it just
means I'm doing whatever the [__] I want
and I'm doing it the best I can and so
like for example if they Chang the rules
of the game for you that in order to win
you had to I don't know [__] kill
your liver something no I'm just you
whatever then you would have to make the
decision do I want to win by the a rules
or do I wi my mind exactly and I would
leave right that's I think that is the
difference between a champion who wins
for the approval and a champion who wins
for themselves yeah is that if they
change the rules if your vision of what
a champion is no longer aligns with the
third party approval then you don't do
it you don't
play and I think there's a lot of wisdom
in choosing what games to play for sure
not feeling like you have to I never
want to feel like I have to oh dude my
number one rule in life like I'll do
everything in the world to not have to
do anything so fun story about cabs so
you don't know this about me but I
trained cabs every single day for more
than 10 years and I developed 1090 is in
my foot from doing so many set of Cales
so I did seven sets of 20 and then your
Cal's shown no my Cals are still fine
but they were uh they were I had a girl
that I did it was like why don't you
train your cabs and I was like I [__]
train them all the
times and so that I went from 3 days a
week doing them at the
end to doing them seven sets at the
beginning as in my cabs but this I
haven't trained cabs right now like me
doing this with you this the first time
I've trained cabs in like probably a
year really like literally haven't done
any reps and it was because I got 10 I I
like I I was struggling walking cuz
there was some muscle in like the base
of my foot it's like under my big toe
but I'll do this cuz I had the champ in
town so of course maybe now you'll
stretch and train Cavs again yeah all I
have to do is I have to stretch my CS
[Music]
out oh [__] this is a really good cap
machine so so that's the thing is like I
hate the load but I love the way this
the lever is perfect so you don't have
to put a lot on it either nice the range
of motion moves so much yeah my calvs
are going to be crippled just for doing
like three sets they're going to be
[__] smoked yeah if you don't train
Cals they get [__] oh you're destroyed
yeah the donkey calf over there is what
Built My
cabs and um standing single leg off a
box is his body
weight yep yeah I started doing um I did
them years ago is one of the things that
like broke through my C like growing
it's just funny is like I um I I don't
train chest anything Asos that last time
because I just always had a decent
enough chest but like if someone like
doesn't know how to grow cabs I'm like I
can [__] tell you how to grow cabs
the biggest thing was super deep you
already know this but like super deep
stretch yeah and so what I would do is
I'd do like 20 or 30 reps body weight on
one one leg off a box underneath of a
pull-up bar and then once I reached
failure I would start counting and so
then I would do assisted negatives or
like you know assisted positives and
like the level of pain that like of like
cooling yourself to the full Flex yeah
when you're just lower oh yeah and then
you like let it down and then you you
really make sure that you get that last
little that last little bit I was like I
did it with clients once and I because I
had just discovered this technique for
myself and I like could barely walk and
I did it with these ladies who I was
training they came in on so it was like
Friday they came on a Monday and they
were like they like couldn't they're
like I couldn't go to the dance this
weekend because I couldn't put heels on
they're like literally could not walk
like and so I felt
accomplished job well done yeah I felt
like I did something yeah [__] just
like control negative yeah are such a
secret to making anything grow I'll do
those like I'll go up with two feet yeah
and then lift one foot and then lower
down like same concept yeah somebody
gave me a cue that was trying to get
your shoelaces perpendicular just like
your foot just cuz you're there like
perpendicular like like it you can't
really do it but like maybe baller but
like it's like so how's being a dad dude
it's good it's chaos it's good it's
chaos it's up body right good for SLE
horrible for bodybuilding but now we've
got help at night now which is like oh
good the biggest cheat code man like my
wife is a saint so she handles like the
the hard part of all they not competing
anymore no she stopped in 2016 she won
the Olympia in
2016 that she kind has some health
issues and then just so your kids are a
champion breeding stck yeah they are
that way used to be Lea got LIF at 315
for reps in the midd gym so I'm just you
know I'm just putting it out there yeah
you good on this do one more you're do
one more I'm going to my CS are going I
already know they're going to be cook
all right don't worry Daniel I know you
wanted the shop there's the shot still
got it I'll give give you a lefty or
you not anymore I have 10 to 9s in my
[__] toe now the old man excuse the
old man I'm going to do the hit thing
cuz I that was the first time I've done
legs in a while that I was not with no
pain y cuz I do my warmup to get to like
a two out of 10 pain I'm like whatever
yeah but that was like a one out of 10
like I had some but like how many
warm-up sets you normally do of the
actual I just recently started doing
like three proper the A and that helped
a lot yeah I was just going straight and
I was like this is horrible yeah that's
brutal I feel like it was like my
muscles are just tearing off like just
not horable yeah no there's like a lot
of actual science behind you even just
your nervous system turning on with
proper warmups and everything your
muscles are literally aren't even
activating until then yeah they're yeah
they're just like what's going on
yeah please don't do
this
nice
okay oh [__] easy this is such we it's
the best cap machine ever used dude it's
good this one's sweet because you can
have the full stack this this is where I
I built this and the and standing uh
single leg are the two things that like
Built My CS but like this guy like all
the way
up and just like yeah who makes this
this is nebula nebula yeah where' you
find this hard to find I us have all
these dealers that I have like on speed
dial they like kind of serious I don't I
like the way this feels and also feels
really good gives you a crazy stretch CU
they bent over yeah yeah it's one of
those ones where when you put weight on
it like is even better kind of thing you
do 400 lb am weight on top I did when I
was at my Peak you're a big boy yeah
when I was a big
boy yeah yeah I had this 100 lb plate
that I had but I haven't done cads in
year so we'll see see what my C drink
can still like probably
[Music]
bad Kevin's going to make a maelly
motivation video of you
[Music]
nice yeah yeah that's where I like smoke
those yeah this also goes up too so you
can adjust uh this yeah so you can go up
a little higher for cuz I was on lless
setting come I'm good like that yeah but
know I like I mean it's a big piece but
um I TR I I mean I train on this every
day for a real time that and the single
Lake are the two things that I did for
my C did you have all this somewhere
else before you moved here yeah my my
house in Austin I had had I had like
half the I had everything I about half
these pieces do you want to do something
else my legs are cooked but I can do
whatever I'm with the champ so I mean we
can do a little quick quens all today
okay unless you're cooked cook no I can
do like zero rest back and forth mhm
[Music]
people are like you're taller than I
expected so
thanks Cuz um Trevor you Dr cash you
near him anyways no he's like you have
sh eye proportions he's like so on
camera he's like you look like you're
five five yeah so my my legs are
actually super short which is good for
like leg moves like I have super short
femur really long torsa are they good
for squatting yeah did you pull Sumo or
conventional Sumo oh God this guy I pull
conventional t on my back and that
switched to Sumo then I hurt my
hips yeah I was 100 lbs weaker on Sumo
than conventional I could do so much
more volume on Sumo yeah and so that
kind of made up for it but weirdly
my deadlift made its biggest gains this
is going to sound insane doing one set
of 20 a week like your one R Max
did cuz I did the same I did like the
[__] pyop pin chart and you know like
531 like I did all of the low rep like
three sets of four all the tradition and
like my deadlift didn't move for like 3
years and I was like I was like
competing and like carage I was like so
upset about it and so then I was like
[__] it and so jug I don't know if you
know jug or not GT jts Chad Wesley Smith
okay well he was the power lifting world
yeah yeah so he was yeah he was being in
the power lifting worlds like football
training and stuff and so we had this
thing called The Jug jug method this is
like 10 years ago and it was all this
super high rep stuff he basically took
wendler's 531 which is a parallel thing
program and just like tripled the bullet
so instead of like sets of 53 and one it
was sets of like 201 151 yeah but like
am wraps I basically ignored everything
in the program but the deadlifts was
like 20s and I was like well I'll do
that I'll see how that goes and I just I
just did sets of 20 and I added 10 lb a
week and I did it for like 16 weeks and
added like 160 lb to my
20 and I was like so did your W Max go
up too though oh yeah well I mean I'm
guessing cuz I was close to my one rep
max on my 2 R Max by the true yeah yeah
so hopefully yeah so like the end of it
I did like I think I did I have a video
of doing like
465 for 20 Jesus and then I was like
this is
stupid that's enough oh yeah and this is
when I was eating like the 6,000
calories a day thing the burritos oh
dude I was like you know Milos is the
one who said like there's no such thing
as overtraining only undereating and
like I say as a natural guy who did that
um I feel like I can kind of attest to
it like I drink a lot of volum how old
were you
25 yeah I mean I feel like when you're
25 and under around there you can do
whatever you want I I at the gym I was a
gym owner I lift the gym yeah and I
trained that was all I did I ate and I
trained that's literally all I did when
I was doing that it was eight hours a
day of food and training yeah I've
decreased my loading increased my warm
up everything more like proper and I'm
just in more pain
out you said you do more warm up less
volume and you're in more pain is
I that sounds right yeah so that's what
I was doing I did the 20 rep sets for
deadlift and I was doing uh three sets
of 20 on Squat and I got up to 45 for 20
well barell back squats we're squatting
we're squatting I was I was 235 natural
that's big I mean that's a [__] for
natural that's a lot of [__] R um and
uh and then um I benched so bench has
been my biggest natural LIF like built a
bench every time I touch the bench it
blows up and so I don't bench which is
why I into it but for the six I only did
it for 6 weeks I put 35 lbs on naturally
I the pictures musle what was your 20
rep max for bench so I hadn't benched in
like a year or two yeah but I did it for
this little cycle and so I was doing
seven sets of everything seven sets of
bench seven sets of not deadlift and
squat but seven sets of rows leg presses
I did banded leg press seven sets of 20
yeah that's how I grew I was I started
as 245 for seven sets of 5 and 6 weeks
later I benched uh 3.95 for one and I
had never like I didn't put a yeah
anything on there so like
I think the week of I did like 335 for 7
sets of five like six weeks yeah but but
I like I cuz I only had that in that one
lift and then I just know that there are
guys who have that on all their lifts
it's just like that's my worst lift so
it's your bench that is that horrible
bench my one rep max ever was 415 you
were probably bodybuilding bench right I
was like power of thing benching which
is 6
in so when you train I mean do you
do you have programming that you follow
this year is the first year I had ever
follow in a program I love that like
that confir like it's so
confirming I
mean you know it in your field there's
an art to being good yeah and you it's
you if you think you need to follow a
perfect program yeah if someone took
everything I did orever someone have
took everything you did and did it again
even if you did it that you were
following a plan instead of just doing
it naturally you wouldn't be here yeah
it's really
interesting because the hardest thing to
develop is
intuition it's like how can like when
when you're like I got it today I'm
going to I'm going to gas it like can
someone teach you that I don't know I
mean I definitely know like for work I
have seasons where like I gas it you
know what I mean where I'm like I'm
working 16 hours I'm taking every
stimulate I know of and like and I'm
like not getting as much sleep as I
should but I can just keep pushing and
then there's some days where I like wake
up and I'm like
no not today night today yeah and so I I
was I was I put it on my my profile was
like I don't have like I work like
weekday weekends are all the same for me
so basically I wake up if I feel good I
work and if I wake up and I feel like
[__] I change this the nature of the
work I do yeah so it's like if I don't
feel good I'll play more meetings I'll
take more calls cuz I'm not like I'm not
going to be doing deep work yeah but if
I wake up and I'm like dude I could cure
cancer today then I'm like all right let
me write a book chapter like let me
script out like a a a presentation or
something that's like really deep and
I'll just tell the team like cancel some
of my calls or move them like I'm going
to be in the zone today yeah but I also
Imagine over time whether consciously
subconsciously you know that like when
you wake up on those shitty days doing
certain things that you can at least do
uhhuh at the right capacity will put you
back into a place where you feel good to
oh [__] where most people are like I'm
going to take the day off I don't feel
good and then next thing you know it's
been a year and they've taken the whole
year what's up
Julio I'm glad you came for legs cuz
legs is what like I can push on upper
body but like I hesitated I was like I
want to ask someone to train legs with
me and I was like yeah [__] it we I'll
trade with you I got the Hotpot
okay you guys know seum he was TI it on
so with some of the drinks the seum Ks
are his his
uh and then you get this probably even
more than I do but like the generic hey
big guy like hey Jim that way or
whatever the [__] no matter what someone
says and you know half the time it's
some sort of left-handed compliment or
whatever I just say like just trying to
catch up to you bro and so it doesn't
matter what they but like I've had so
many people who like said something
meane and I'm like she trying to catch
up to you bro and then they're like ah
Fu I was being dick you know and that
that's always been my my big counter
yeah for some reason I always get people
like are you like that se bum guy and my
response is just no but I get that all
the time and then like probably % the
time people are like oh and then I just
walk away that's it I'm also equally
awkward and antisocial so if someone
comes up and like do I know you're from
somewhere I'm like I don't know probably
not and then I just leave not from
somewhere so training wise you just
Train by feel and you just consistently
out waight when you can I have a program
now well every year but until now I was
pretty like consistent in what I would
do and movement I just knew in my brain
yeah I know like my top movements when I
start if it's incline chest dumbbell
press it's if it's pendulum squat if
it's de Ben over Rose I'm like last year
did this much so I'm going to do this
much this week yeah and youed work to
like I'm going to add 20 lbs to it or 30
lbs or it was for a while it was like
all right I'm going to do this for six
and then I got eight and I got 10 I'll
put a 25 on I'm back down to six and
eight and then 10 all the stuff that I
know is like stick to a handful of lifts
don't do a lot of variation slowly i'
progress it you know reps or weight
right but then like I just noticed that
I had less motivation to train and so
like I was more prone to skip days and
things like that yeah and like this was
today was harder than I would normally
train my legs so I'll probably like
it'll probably [__] my like I'm supposed
to train legs tomorrow yeah so I just
like I'll probably if you train L
tomorrow I'd be impressed
yeah yeah so I'll just like I'll skip
that and maybe I'll skip a second like
cuz it's every other day so I would have
trained Lakes tomorrow and two days from
there so I'll probably just skip the
next two and then hit it again like if
you don't have that flexibility like if
you were in town like oh I'm falling
like why bother like you what I mean
like I've had people there's like three
you know Fitness dudes who have you know
whatever they were in town I saw this
kid who's like not a competitor he was
like I'm following a program and so all
the dudes were lifting all the big guys
are lifting together throwing weights R
and he's like sitting Indian style ins
side like I'm following it's like dude
you're missing the point yeah like
you're not going to get be like 40 and
be like man I'm really glad I followed
that progress I was 22 and you know
training with those guys and then going
home being fired up about training with
them what result till your list going up
more too right the motivation you get
from that would be more oh so much more
yeah like and in the memory and like all
the positive experience that come from
it did you listen to music when you
train yeah what do you listen to it
varies alternative rock Eminem Kanye
West 9s hip hop yeah I listen to more or
less the same stuff I'm not a music
person it's the only time I listen to
music is when I train yeah and so I like
so bad that a friend of mine from high
school gave me this CD it was rap CD 1
through six and I uploaded it on my iPod
and then like I went through all of
college and then we were hanging out a
couple years later he's like so what you
you know what do you listen to now on
your train I was like
the N that you made me and he was like
the what and I was like yeah the one
that you made me he was like in high
school and I was like yeah rap CD 1
through six I still listen to he's like
dear God he's like dude there's been
things that have Haden he's like
Eminem's had two CDs since then I'll
make you a new mix and SPO out by then
you just still have an
iPod like I've got a zoon yeah I didn't
even have one of those yeah it's weird
because now I'm turning to 35 in like a
couple months in August and I was like I
am like like when I it before I turned
30 I was like young and successful and
now I'm just a white
dude yeah I felt that too I was like
holy [__] you're only 25 and you won the
Olympia now you're like all right you're
the old guy now yeah you're just yeah
it's I'm just a guy yeah what's
interesting with um like with the
Olympia in terms of like competitive
landscape and whatnot is that like in
the game of business everyone is a
competitor like everyone's in the game
it's just some people don't know it and
that's what I find kind of interesting
about like the business world is like
you compete against the world and it's
Global yeah and you compe against guys
they 90 and like like kind like you
can't age out how old was Kendall Jenner
she be she became the youngest self-made
billionaire and then they revoked it
they did like she wasn't actually or
yeah the numbers weren't what she
overstated some of her numbers like 9
months later after she got into all of
the pr after I had gone into a deep
7-Day depression because of how
inadequate I felt as a result of
compared to this little w
yeah no I mean it was actually like it
was actually weirdly it was a it was a
it was a career defining moment for me
really it sounds ridiculous to say when
I saw her on the cover fors a 19 years
old as a billionaire I felt like a
failure I I did I was I was 20 I think I
was 26 or 27 can't remember it was and I
I taken home $17 million in income that
year and I was like I'm hot
[__] I'm [__] cool and then it was
just
like 19-year-old girl billionaire I was
just like
I suck at everything and that was
actually the moment where I was like she
understand so I fundamentally think that
if someone makes more money than me then
they know something about business that
I don't she was the one that got me on
to brand was that she was able to make
than me because she had a brand and I
was like maybe there's something to this
and I did I also encourage your
philosophy to not compare to other
people though H well to compete against
yourself and all that so yeah yeah so
there's a really good one there is that
there's a difference between criticism
and and uh insults so if you insult
thought yourself and you make a judgment
if you criticized you point out a
discrepancy so she's bigger than I am in
this way why that's criticism like I
could do better judgment is and because
of that you are bad yeah all right be
easy my friend yes sir appreciate you
gin appreciate you have a wonderful day
guys
[Music]